the next topic on today's agenda uh is a
clip from Joe Rogan I'm a huge Joe Rogan
fan absolutely love The Joe Rogan
Experience and have watched many many
hours of it he is also discussing this
issue of chemically castrating children
he has some guy on his show and he puts
a very simple question to him for
whatever reason this adult man is
completely bewildered by a very simple
question that's where we're at guys
that's where we're at at in our society
and in our culture today that adults who
should be competent enough to comprehend
a basic simple
question can't even answer it simply
because of their fear of seeming
Politically Incorrect anyway let's let's
roll the clip why do you have to give
them hormones to make them more of a
girl uh
because I'm sorry can you explain on the
question it's a simple question if you
say that the child thinks it's a girl so
you're going to give the child hormones
If the child thinks it's a girl let it
be a girl why are you adding hormones if
you're shooting hormones into a child
and you're affecting the child's
development you're saying that's not a
choice that's nonsense of course it's a
choice you're choosing to chemically
change this child's body you're choosing
to inject things into this child's body
on a regular basis that are going to
radically affect the physical
development of their body and you're
saying that this isn't a choice well
it's definitely a choice to do
that
he's completely baffled by the question
he he he can't comprehend that Joe has
asked him something like this he doesn't
know how to respond this obviously comes
from like I said a fear of seeming
Politically Incorrect a fear of saying
the wrong thing and I mean look let's
firstly address the fact that this is
becoming a real problem today people
can't say what they really think because
they don't want to get cancelled or you
know in some cases they don't want to
lose their job for saying the wrong
thing and it's happening I mean here in
the UK they're about to pass the Online
safety bill which is essentially a law
it's waiting on the Royal Ascent but it
I can see it happening in the next sort
of month or so it's essentially a law
that limits freedom of speech so we are
literally living in a time where you
can't say what you really think you can
only say what you think so far as it
agrees with the general status quo of
society so so long as it agrees with
what the government deems acceptable
opinions or not but that's a completely
different issue look the fact is that
the left and the trans Community
constantly say that biology has nothing
to do with your gender identity so why
is it that if your biology your
physical biological fact of being either
male or female if that has nothing to do
with your gender identity then why do
you need to change your biology to
reaffirm that gender
identity there's a lack in the logic
here it doesn't make any sense so if
biology has nothing to do with gender
identity and a little girl identifies as
a little boy surely going off of their
whole ideology that's enough for that
little girl to qualify or to pass as a
little boy so why is it then that they
would need to be chemically castrated
injected with a bunch of
hormones to become something else it's
the same idea with when you hear about
stereotypes and gender is a social
construct and it's reinforced by the
clothes we wear the fact that we say
things like pink is a girl's color and
blue is a boy's color and boys like cars
and trucks and fighting and girls like
dolls and gardening and and baking if
that's the case that how you dress your
your interests has nothing to do with
your gender then the whole transgender
thing falls apart because if gender is
just how you feel in the inside and how
you present on the outside has nothing
to do with it then why is it men who
want to be women where
dresses if the external side the
materialistic things is just a social
construct and things we've invented
stereotypes then why why do it the whole
thing just Mak makes completely no sense
to me and I I constantly find this flaw
in their logic they say oh it's just a
social construct we've invented it it's
all about how you feel on the inside
fine feel that way on the inside but if
that was the case why are you guys
chopping your dicks off why are you guys
getting chemically castrated if it was
all just about the feeling on the inside
you wouldn't be mutilating yourself on
the outside but hey look that that's
just what I think and I'm aware that
there is a very small group of people
with a very loud voice who disagree with
me but I would like to think that this
is just basic common sense I'm aware
that the commonness of this sense is
seemingly no longer common but hey I
think hopefully most sane normal people
would agree with me why don't you let me
know what you think